so the next people will be leaning
around an assistant professor in
computer science at University of
Illinois prior to joining the university
they receive each from MIT so today I'm
again talking about analysis of Nakamoto
consensus so you might be wondering why
yet another proof we already had four or
five of these and in fact even this
morning the first talk was on exactly
this topic so my main motivation was to
simplify the proof so nakamoto consensus
is this extremely simple particle I
think it can be described in these two
lines the particle is basically this my
are the longest chain and when you have
a new longest chain you send it to all
and also you commit if blocks for if you
commit all the blocks that are buried
deep but somehow it got this reputation
that it's difficult to formally analyze
rigorously proof that Nakamoto solves
consensus and basically I want to show
you it should not it should not have
been that way analysis can also be quite
simple just to give you a quick overview
I hope I can convince you this is
nothing difficult this is a simple
simple result in people proof I'm going
to show you that Nakamoto consensus it
solves consensus if this condition holds
so very short formula where alpha is the
onions the mining rate beta is the
malicious mining rate and Delta is the
communication delay if alpha times this
erased 2 to alpha delta is greater than
beta then nakamoto and the nakamoto
constants particle works
so when I say it's offs consensus I am
using the traditional consensus
properties safety and liveness safety
means all the honest notes they commit
the same sequence of blocks and the
liveness mean means every transaction is
essentially is eventually included in
the sequence so I want to claim this
prove is simple and but we don't have a
mathematical way to model simplicity so
bear with me I have to use some hand
wavy metrics right so this is the entire
proof about two and half pages I think I
could just let you read it and you
probably will probably be done in 30
minutes right but well has to be your
talk so I'll walk you through it here on
the statement so because it tasted like
this but the probability is somewhere
right yes yeah it's safe alive with some
probability with overwhelming
probability
okay and my proof builds on top of
several amazing and inspiring works
including rajim o hasta talked from the
morning let me just quickly view a quick
overview of how this area evolved all
right so the first Brown groundbreaking
work is Garre at all its gkl it's the
first rigorous proof for Nakamoto
consensus before that we the analysis
kind of went about ruling out particular
attacks like the Nakamoto himself did
analysis assuming this is the best
attack ever that can ever exist he
proves that attack would not work and
great our paper is the first to rule out
all possible attacks so the only thing
that's not nice about it is that it's a
it's employs this what I call lockstep
synchrony model which is based around
at the end of the at the beginning of
around everybody send a message at the
end of the round everybody receives the
previous round message and then we do
the net take our next action right so in
some sense this means there's no
communication delay in the network
everybody always received the message at
the same time and then you can see if we
plug in Delta equals zero then the
result I have degenerates to that case
but even to show this result I think
they need about 10 pages of proofs the
next work is past dementia that so that
they are the first to recognize the
importance of introducing this doubted
delay I am well I didn't cheat is the
default
oh yeah comment on how I cheated in the
end so their result is essentially this
formula it's also the honest mining rate
needs to be multiplied with a discount
that's essentially the mining rate loss
right after the last on if the honest is
greater than malicious money rate then
Nakamoto consensus is secure meaning
saving life to prove this result they
need about sixteen pages and it's easy
to verify that this is this result is
looser than what I'm going to show you
next up is Raj Mojave per okay so I
though so they introduced the Markov
chains to tighten up this results and
their analysis are actually quite simple
it doesn't add any pages so it's the
same amount of work complexity as the
previous one but the complexity kind of
lies in somewhere else that they're the
end result is not so simple not so nice
I saw the instead of having a few
variables they needed that this quantity
to be greater than data whereas these
are from the Markov chain the
probability with stationary distribution
and so on right if we look at what those
things are this is 0 0 and L 1 0 they
themselves are summation and the
summation has this one extra term that's
the P sub I less than Delta which itself
is another summation so it's I would say
it's a less of it's a more complicated
result in the end okay so at some point
I claimed so when they choose
that's the transmission today it's
listening to assume a randomized
scheduler or so it means every message
if it's from one honest to another
honest it arrives within the other time
but it can take anywhere between zero
and the other time that's that can be
decided by the adversary there's no
public distribution the adversary can
decide arbitrarily how much time it
wants each message to take
okay that defines the functions of brief
instead device of the prefix
so puncture the decides given the prefix
which messages to leave up next
yet the adverse we can control that
anyway he likes I'm not requiring the
adversary to explicitly state how it
wants to do that alright so I thought my
result is tighter than that but I think
I have to take that back that claim
because there's a recent paper by Joe
that shows this summation three nested
summation is actually exactly the same
as the formula I have there right and to
show that they need another 13 pages and
137 equations they claim this exactly
same I haven't verified but I kind of
believe that because in the end
fundamentally the approach are very
similar and they should not give
different results most like most things
this thing was that I know a bunch of
similar situations yes yes it's still
there so Markov chain is still useful
for that so all I'm saying is if you
want to prove give a proof to nakamoto
or to ghost we do not have to rely on
Markov chain
but Roger also did analyzes the best
attacks right to show how successful
best attacks can be that I do not claim
I have any better analysis
so now let me jump into this proof so I
want to also need to first to define the
model and write kind of a did most of
that for me so the first assumption we
have to make is that there is an
on-message delay bound so that's the
standard synchrony assumption a couple
of comments
so Bitcoin Nakamoto runs in a
peer-to-peer network right for the sake
of my analysis I'm assuming
point-to-point connection
I believe you insist on having a
peer-to-peer network we can still make
that work it's just that the stoutest
should take into account all the
different hops in the network and so
delta is an upper bound for a message to
travel through all hops the next thing I
think the audience already asked the
adversary controls message delays within
zero to Delta it can it has freedom to
to delay each message anytime in that
range but you cannot delay a message
more than Delta
so third this is a quick comment so this
model is exactly the same as in the PSS
and keeper paper but they call it some
they call it the other things they call
it a racing canoe of hydro synchrony I
personally felt that's misnomer and I'm
glad that uh Raj agreed with me so I
would call this model non lockstep
synchrony its synchrony because we have
message delay bound culture synchrony
and we have an own message delay bound
Delta hydro synchrony and asynchrony
means either we have no bound or we have
a band but no one knows about it right
so those are harder models to deal with
thinking about I don't have any rounds
that's the oh yeah yeah I want to
emphasize here my mother doesn't use
rounds so it's a whenever I receive a
message I'm going to take the next
action immediately I don't have to wait
till prescribed runs so in fact in the
previous models they also rounds to me
is more of an artifact because they want
the round to be infinitely small so
essentially it is the continuous time
model but I think they it may simplify
some of their analysis that's why they
introduced the round
okay so yeah and that the next
assumption is that I assumed mining is
this ideal memoryless event which
basically means it's a Poisson process
and I'll use alpha and beta to denote
the collective honest money rate and the
collective malicious man you wait I
basically honest notes collectively well
my alpha blocks in unit amount of time
in sometimes maybe our Phi is a point
six block per ten minute and beta is a
point four block per 10 minute speaking
okay and so lastly one more ideal
assumption I assume afferent data do not
change they stay the same throughout the
particle so this is not really what's
happening because in Bitcoin people will
come and go so the mining rate fluctuate
a little bit and every two weeks it's
adjusted to the 10-minute mark
but essentially I'm assuming here the
difficulty adjustment mechanism is
perfect it takes effect in real time
perfect means alpha plus beta
are you assuming output and better
individually go check there's a stronger
assumption I see I did not have to do it
that way I could i can assume say lambda
which is the total network man you eight
does not change and Arvind beta to
fractions and as long as they satisfy
that equation good catcher I could have
made it slightly the particle is I got a
block then I start mining I will compute
hashes in what using whatever rate I can
whenever I tried whenever managed to
find the next block extending the
previous one then I announce the block
yeah then you're assuming the detector
is following the book - honestly no of
course not the attacker will do whatever
he wants to do mining is at anytime I'm
working on the longest chain I know for
honest for malicious at any time it can
try to extend from anywhere he likes but
all it tries to do is to find a block
that extends somewhere from the chain no
I think I believe the Nakamoto particle
really it doesn't need to use time all
I'm doing is I'm trying to compute
hashes as fast as I can whenever I find
a block I'm going to announce it to the
no I disagree I think he's actually a
let's idealize the model then
yeah oh the bad guys can mine a block
and hide it right and send it at some
later time
the bad guys may not extend the longest
chain may attend somewhere in the middle
all of the things that it can do in your
model I'm Masood I'm also adopting it's
really no difference because yours you
also want your tiny rounds to be really
really tiny right to be infinitely small
but when you take it in tennis more it's
exactly the same model as I have here
I guess they don't say because it's very
different to assume you have an alias
object look around America yeah let me
comment on that later yeah all right oh
by the way I'm also assuming there's
only honest and versus malicious no
rational behavior that is a big part in
Bitcoin but all about analysis do not
tackle that for now right so some
premium preliminary Chernoff bound i
think everybody knows that
for a sum of independent boolean random
variables it cannot deviate too much
from its me there's a very similar bound
for a Poisson process if a Poisson
process if a Poisson distribution has a
mean of lambda T then it also cannot
deviate too much from that mean this
should be natural because the Poisson is
basically a infinite summation of balut
Bernoulli Bernoulli that are variables
as expected all right so key idea of the
proof is essentially the same we're
trying to count the number of useful
blocks and we'll show that a number of
useful honest blocks is more than the
number of maliciously
mind blocks okay so what I mean by that
I'm going to put all the honest blocks
on a time axis based on when they are
produced when their mind right we hope
they form a chain so now let's assume
there are there no malicious person I'm
trying to define things but occasionally
that it's not that good situation
occasionally to honest mind blocks will
extend the same block why did that
happen it's because they are mined too
close to each other so this latter block
was not aware of the first block so in
particular this how close is too close
it's within Delta if it's more than
Delta then the latter block was aware of
the previous block and then it will be
building on top of it
so if two blocks are mine too close to
each other then one of them will be
wasted
okay so let's formally define that
notion I'm going to define one is the
block mined at time T is called a numb
tailgater if no other block is mined
within the doubt a time before it
otherwise it's a tailgater so then this
is a tailgater and the other blocks are
non tailgaters
and we know that the inter-arrival in
these gaps for a Poisson process follow
independent exponential distributions I
saw the probability that any of these is
non tailgater is e raise to half a
doubter that's the term that shows up in
the end
and they are independent so I'm going to
call this quantity G because it's
shorter
lastly I'm also defining another notion
called a loner it is a block if a block
is not mind if no block is mine the
Delta before it and no block is mined
out after it then it is called a loner
it's a far away from everybody I on this
figure these two blocks those two purple
blocks are loners this one is not right
because even though it does not tailgate
the previous one it is tailgated by the
next block
okay so these useful blocks they have
some nice properties in particular none
tailgaters they do not have the same
height and the loner does not share
height with any other on its block and
the proof is very simple it suffice to
show that if two blocks do not tailgate
one another then they will not be on the
same height because the latter one is
aware of the previous one so at least
the latter one will be attempted at a
higher height
so next we're going to show there are
many many of these useful blocks in
particular in a time interval of
duration T there will be roughly
speaking gr fatty non tailgaters and G
square alpha T loners except for smoke
abilities by the way I should mention
loner is the convergence opportunity
defined by the PSS paper and in the edge
talk and the Markov chain raj introduced
is basically to count the number of
loners and I'm going to show you a
simple way to count the number of loners
okay so let's do the first part first so
in the situation of time time T I'll use
n to denote the number of honest blocks
mind so n follows a Poisson distribution
because of a Poisson tail bound is at
least one minus half Delta alpha T
except for small probabilities we also
said each honest the block is non
tailgater with a probability G which is
e raise to minus Alpha Delta right so
then using a Chernov is at least one
minus half Delta G times n plugging is
what we have
okay so next let's count the number of
loners which are almost the same there
are n number of honest blocks and number
of loners is basically that the
summation of boolean random variables
each loner has a chi-square probability
each block has a chi-square probability
of being a loner because it has to be a
non tailgater and the blocks next to it
after it it also has to be a non
tailgater but the only complication is
that we cannot use Chernoff bound
because these things are actually
dependent because they share this
variable so luckily why I and why I plus
two independent cuz they are derived
from independent exponential
distributions therefore we can break up
the summation into two parts even an odd
and we invoke Chernov separately on both
parts and we will get the results
does that mean that your your
underestimate take the number of your
lowness you know i think we can show
this is tight
using a Markov chain argument this is
actually tight
all right so yeah quick summary long
tailgaters do not share other do not
share height with other non tailgaters
and there are that many of them loners
to not share height with any other
honest blocks and there are this many of
them I need to go a bit faster a long
time so liveness liveness traditionally
it's broken up into two parts chain
growth and chain quality growth says a
time T the chain is at least this long
and quantities as among those blocks
some fraction of them are honest in
growth directly follows from the
properties of non tailgaters because non
tailgaters have different heights so the
chain length is at least as as long as
the number of the non tailgaters which
is what we have we just wrong right
quality so chain length is at least
roughly speaking G of RT and the worst
case is that all the malicious blocks
make it into the longest chain that's
when the honest fraction is the smallest
which is this quantity I am using Delta
over 3 here because it turns out 1 plus
Delta of Delta over 3 divided by 1 minus
that obviously is less than 1 plus
daughter
okay so lastly safety so safety
statement says if we commit by waiting
until blocks are buried by K deep that
commit rule will be correct except for
exponential in K probability that's the
hardest proof
so okay I don't have time to go through
this carefully but essentially this is
the situation we're analyzing
it's also in the gkl paper right if we
violate safety at some point we need to
have two diverging chains that are that
are length K or longer I'm going to call
B prime 0 to be their last common
ancestor and B 0 to be their last honest
common ancestor so I'm going to mark
their heights and when they are mind
then I'm defying Y to be the set of all
owners that are mined within this period
and defining Z to be all the malicious
blocks mind within this period right now
we can show a contradiction but Z should
be at least Y but also Z cannot be
larger than what
for the first part we just need to pair
every loner with a malicious block by
the way we do it is the following if a
loner is like in this region then we can
pair it with this block by definition
that is the last honest ancestor so all
of these blocks are malicious okay so
that is a Z is a malicious block if Y is
over here then we'll pair it with the
corresponding block on the divergent
chain because I showed you loners do not
share height with other honest blocks so
this pair I find must be a malicious
block so every loner is my is paired to
a malicious block therefore Z is at
least as large as Y on the other hand we
said the rate at which honest the miners
can produce loners is faster than the
rate at which malicious miners can find
blocks right so therefore it's actually
very straightforward that Y should be
larger than Z it's roughly speaking Y
should be G square alpha T where Z is
beta T right when we are waiting for
blocks to be buried deep t minus 2 Delta
is roughly speaking P right so
intuitively our safety condition is
exactly that
little more steps it's also very simple
alright so lastly to avoid this
contradiction some unlikely events
regarding the tale needs to happen and
that is the probability that Nakamoto
loses safety and all of those events
happen with the race to delta square
beta Chi right but we want the
probability to be expressed in K so
that's the last catch we need to show
that T is at least linear in K what is T
is the time to find K blocks in a chain
which is the summation of K iid
exponential distributions which is the
Erlang distribution if you plug in to
its cumulative density function we can
show that K times beta is at least okay
so here why not to trance cave because
you have to evade divergences right
so I would say maybe I could have been
tighter yeah like yeah possibly
impossible yeah all right so yeah that's
at the end to summarize Nakamoto South's
consensus if this condition holds this
is not known to be tight because the
beste attack works only for only when G
alpha is less than Delta so there is a
gap there I personally felt it's our
proof is now tight the attack is indeed
the best attack
[Applause]
I try to understand today there it comes
in the picture how sort of the delaying
of messages influences the probabilities
that's right so I'm not showing you how
the attacker plays a role here which is
which actually should be the case
because this proof holds for any
adversarial behavior so basically the
best attack we have is the adverse
reminds mine system chain and the delay
everyone is block to Delta right then
every tailgater from the honest will be
a often block so the honest chain will
grow at the pub at the rate of a non
tailgater which is Chiappa right if the
bad guy has more has a higher mine rate
than that then the bad guys private
chain will outgrow on its node
so I like the general books in order to
get a good balance and crumbs I also
very worried about the general approach
to just saying that you can abstract
away what the attacker is doing so
assume for instance that like what this
protocol have their company if you can
take one don't get more it's another dog
that was also something you can take a
block that's a bug on Bitcoin so there
is nothing in your knowledge destroyed
considering your target this is you know
the classic traditional photography that
we mix some make assumption but the
derivative may be assume realm or not
can I see something only assuming that
you have like respect in attacking to
extend blocks it's dangerous it costs
nothing to mind for the guy yeah that's
not my responsibility right you know if
you're if your plot if your protocol so
all I'm claiming is that if your
particles mining is secure than this
analysis the price of course nobody it's
okay let's proving a muggle and then you
you if you want you can prove something
or really see nice no no that is the
difference between this analysis yeah
all the time but I'm happy to discuss
why I think this model is captures the
essence
it depends on whether the chair allows
it so yeah I'll speak to introduce in
XSP